there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
october to test for ourselves let's
start off with these new products from
huda beauty's glowish line the luminous
pressed powder and the cheeky vegan
blush i have yet to be disappointed by a
glowish product but this powder wasn't
my favorite it is super silky and soft
but i felt like because it's a luminous
pressed powder on my bare skin it just
highlighted texture in a way i didn't
love i had a feeling i would like this
more over foundation you can use it both
ways so i tried it that way and yep i
feel like it looks smoother over the
foundation than just on my bare skin and
the blush was cute nothing really
special i don't think it's worth paying
21 dollars for a just okay blush
especially one that's so baby sized this
water activated liner from matte lashes
is supposed to be super pigmented and
transfer proof so i was dying to try it
out all you do with these is dip your
brush in some water and wet the liner i
put some on the back of my hand first
just to see how transfer proof it
actually is and it did not move it also
dried down super matte which i love i
hate when black liner has that shiny
satin finish applying it on the eyes was
so easy i actually prefer using these
kinds of liners because i feel like i
just have more control of the product i
can see myself using this all the time
and it actually comes in a set with a
white liner too this is a product that i
don't think i ever would have tried if
it wasn't for this show this is the
makeup by mario master metals eyeshadow
palette and it has all of these really
beautiful metallic shades that can be
used wet or dry i use this orange copper
shade dry first just applying it
straight on the eye with my finger and
these are so smooth and metallic they
really do make your eyes pop then i
scraped up some powder to mix together
with the metal manipulator to basically
turn it into a liquid this is sold
separately by the way using these in the
liquid form intensifies it by like a
thousand it literally looks like liquid
metal on the eyes and the metal
manipulator makes it budge proof so it
won't smudge anywhere i'm still not
super into the idea of a 48
all metallic palette but the quality of
these shadows is so so good next let's
talk about the milani color fetish matte
lipsticks oh my god i think i love these
they are incredibly creamy smooth and
pigmented i love the soft matte finish
they have everything about these feels
more expensive than they actually are
they are so cute definitely recommend
these this color secret in particular is
supposed to be a charlotte tilbury
pillow talk dupe i can't speak on that
because i don't have pillow talk money
but i'm just letting you know and
finally we have the m cosmetics so soft
sticks i have the multi face place stick
which can be used as bronzer or contour
and the blush stick the name does not
lie these are some of the softest most
easy to blend products i've ever used i
don't normally contour but this color
was more on the cool side so i attempted
to contour with it and it was just so
easy to apply and blend same with the
blush the color was a little too light
for me but because they blend in so easy
i think i made it work these are pricey
but so worth it to me
[Music]